[Musique]
X
c'est le sport de descente qui monte
chez nous le long skate compte une
poignée d'adepte sur les quatre points
cardinaux de Lille chacun dans sa région
s'approprie un bout de bitume ù
pratiquer ce sport de dingue il associe
vitesse descente et glisse de la
descente radicale en voilà du côté de
trois bassins sur une route peu
fréquentée par les
[Musique]
voitures là nous sommes
dans l'Ouest entre la petite ravine et
la grande ravine tout près du du spot de
surf de tris bassins donc dans les bas
il y a une route ici qui était affectée
au chantier de la route des tamarin à
l'époque maintenant très peu emprunté
donc on arrive à sécuriser afin de
pratiquer la descente en long skate de
manière
sécurisée les difficultés sont deux
virages principalement où les sorties
sont un peu risqué et la végétation qui
qui évolue sans cesse vu qu'il est pas
très entretenu donc le spot se rétrécit
au fur à mesure ce qui rend le truc
[Musique]
intéressant c'est donc c'est des
skateboard donc plus long avec des
trucks à géométrie différente par
rapport à des skates normaux donc plus
plus
larg et le but du jeu c'est d'arriver en
bas sur plusieurs styles soit à fond
soit en
carbon la pratique c'est descendre une
route s'amuser à surfer le
bitum d'ailleurs ce sont les surfeurs
qui ont inventé le long skate il y a
quelques années suite à une pénurie de
de houle ils voulaient donc encore
surfit ils ont inventé le long skate qui
s'est maintenant développé et
aujourd'hui beaucoup plus de pratiquants
ici à la réunion nous sommes une
vraiment une minorité à pratiquer mais
donc en métropole et partout dans le
monde il y a des événements il y a des
coupes du monde il y a des Coupes de
France championnat de
France don't quite know the distance but
I'm sure far i'm sure it's pretty
far
andk
the
săag
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
săłag